[Music]
italian skiers are back on the slopes
and a place that last year was the
epicenter of the pandemic in europe
as covet 19 ravaged northern italy the
country took tough measures to stave off
disaster
now as case numbers are spiking in
neighboring countries italy will place
more restrictions on unvaccinated people
we want
what lessons can italy teach us about
dealing with the coronavirus pandemic
welcome to your covet 19 special i'm
chris colbert in berlin
last year's dramatic pictures and
europe's second highest death toll
linked to covet 19 seemed to have had an
impact italy already has one of the
strictest anti-infection regiments in
the world and with cases rising again
the country is now barring unvaccinated
citizens from much of public life
time for a booster shot an invitation
message is sent to all those who qualify
for one italian care home staff teachers
and high-risk groups got theirs first
over 40s are up next
there's been an effective vaccination
campaign in italy which is not common
the fact so many people have been
vaccinated is good for everyone
it's also important that each of us pay
attention to where we go
that we always wear a mask and we keep
our distance
all these factors along with
vaccinations have contributed to
controlling the number of infections in
italy
on public transport only those
vaccinated those who've recovered from
infection or have been tested are
allowed on board
the same goes for workplaces
companies that don't check for a
so-called green pass face fines and
employees without it could have their
pay cut
people must pay for their own corona
virus tests in order to push more
italians to get vaccinated
in recent days the number of infections
has risen in italy but there are far
fewer seriously ill people compared to a
year ago
only 475 of 9 000 intensive care beds
are occupied
italy remains optimistic as winter
approaches
only those vaccinated recently recovered
or who've tested negative are allowed on
the country's ski slopes but italy is
hopeful that christmas can be more
relaxed than last year
let's take a closer look at what italy
has been through and which conclusions
we can draw from that together with
walter ricciardi he's a hygiene and
public health professor and with the
intensive care physician enrico storti
bonjourno senori welcome to both of you
enrico let me start with you how hopeful
are you that you and your colleagues
will have less to do over the holidays
i think that we can say that
now the situation is completely
different uh
compared with what we experimented last
year i mean we have of course the virus
circulating in our country
but thanks to the vaccination protocol
that italy
decide to to carry on
i think that now the impact on the
hospital and on the icu particularly by
my perspective is much more
easier to be controlled and so our daily
practically is
absolutely better compared with last
year
walter over to you more than two months
ago italy imposed some of the strictest
anti-covet measures in the world
practically all workers in the country
needed to show proof of vaccination
recovery or a negative test to get to
their job or lose pay now starting
monday the country's super green pass
will basically bar unvaccinated citizens
from much of public life why
because we learned the lesson that this
virus must be anticipated and not
followed and the delta variant really
changed the game so we understood that
only with very strict measures we could
anticipate the spread of the virus and
we could avoid the situation of having a
country that had to be locked again so
essentially this is uh really the
situation as it is now is much better
compared to other countries because we
advance these measures not follow them
how have people been reacting to this
new rule walter
after all very well i mean you know the
vast majority of the countries is
following the rule i would say
more than 90 percent has been vaccinated
and more than 90 percent is falling very
strictly the rule there is a tiny
minority which is very noisy unfortunate
that with some media generating a lot of
anxiety in the country because of this
tiny and noisy minority but after all
the countries is behaving
enrico back to you you said the
situation today
differs greatly from the one
last year
nevertheless we see infections rising
not only throughout europe but also in
italy how worried are you about new
variants occurring like omicron
uh i mean uh as professor richard uh
already said i think that uh we did our
best to be uh ready and to get ready
about this new uh spread of the
different
virus i mean different types of virus
and of course we are worried but i think
that now
we have to to better understand
exactly what are what are the
characteristics of this new variant and
basically uh starting from what we know
now i think that we can say that is a
sort of it's it's powerful in terms of
in
capacity to infect but we didn't know
exactly if this characteristics is able
to sustain a different impact on the on
the illness itself so i think that we
are ready we are now trying to do what
we can actively do
and we are still doing that so we are
not worried but of course we have to be
very careful about what is going on
walter back to you with more than 130
000 deaths linked to covet 19 italy has
the second highest
death toll in europe we've seen the
pictures of coffins being stacked onto
army trucks how much have these images
had an impact on the public and their
behavior during the pandemic
they had an impact absolutely they
really shocked the country and then made
all the people aware that this was not
an ordinary flu this was a serious
disease to be taken into account
particularly because the first wave
struck the best part of the country the
most developed the richest the most
equipped so we were shocked and people
understood that this was serious
unfortunately the second and the third
wave we underestimated the importance of
keeping these measures alive but now we
have learned the lesson
walter what needs to be key
for italy when moving forward in this
pandemic
we believe as dr sorti said that
vaccinating is still the most important
pillar of action but not only we have to
keep a safe distance we have to keep our
universal masking we have to keep
hygiene we have to be very careful in in
mass gatherings so the combination of
the measures is the only way to manage
this pandemic and we are going to do
that
enrico back to you
even with all the precautions some
people will end up being hospitalized
now at the beginning of the pandemic
treatment was scarce how well are you
equipped today
uh no let me say that i think that we
can say that we are we now or better
know this uh this infection this uh the
the direct consequences that this
infection is able to bring
and uh so i feel myself and i can i can
tell you that all the icu community uh
physicians in
in italy we feel ourselves confident
that we can we have
we have all the tools that we need
to control this business unfortunately i
think that in the near future will be
more would be important trying to get
some drugs
and not only how to ventilate and how to
preserve the
patient's lungs
to have a better outcome of this
infection let me say that if we compare
now our treatment
compared with what we did
and what we can do at that time one year
ago i think that now we uh
we have a much more concrete standard
that uh i think it's uh really enough to
treat these patients
intensive care physician enrico storti
and public health professor walter
ricciardi
thank you to your both mille grazie
senori
you're welcome
and now it's time for another one of
your questions here's our science
correspondent derek williams
can you tell us more about the effects
of long covid in kids
one of the few upsides if you will of
sars kobe 2 is that at least during the
active infection
um children are largely spared serious
outcomes like
hospitalization
and death
but that doesn't mean that some of them
won't eventually pay a price um
estimates for
what percentage of children suffer
symptoms associated with long covid in
the weeks and the months following an
infection
they're kind of all over the place
but most researchers in the field seem
to agree now that it's significant
although
recent data indicates thankfully it
might not be as common as we once
thought
some early research postulated
that postcoded symptoms might affect up
to half of all the kids who got it
that estimate has dropped considerably
with a larger recent study
roughly finding more like one in seven
kids are still reporting symptoms
over three months after a covet
infection just like in adults those long
covid symptoms have also been very
wide-ranging in kids um the most serious
reported effect is called
multi-system inflammatory syndrome in
children or
misc
which can lead to organ failure it's
fortunately pretty rare
there have only been around five and a
half thousand cases of it reported in
the u.s so far for instance
more common effects are sometimes but
not always similar
to those reported by adults like
fatigue or labored breathing or
headaches
or changes to the sense of smell and
taste
neurological symptoms like brain fog or
or difficulties concentrating are also
widely reported
some studies show that vaccines appear
to help cut the risk in an adult
of developing long covid if they
experience a breakthrough infection
maybe by as much as half
but
there isn't enough data yet on whether
they also
reduce the risk of it in younger kids
we just haven't been vaccinating them
long enough to know
[Music]
and staying with vaccines the oxford
astrazeneca jab has been credited with
saving millions of lives but some
countries suspended its use after an
extremely rare side effect was reported
that may cause blood clots in some
recipients now researchers in britain
and the united states may have found
what causes the clotting a protein in
the blood is attracted to a key
component of the vaccine
causing a chain reaction with the immune
system astrazeneca scientists took part
in the research and say they are looking
at ways to eliminate the side effect
that's our show for now for more
information check out our website at
dw.com covet19 i'm chris coburn berlin
thanks for watching stay safe
you